en este vídeo vamos a fijarnos en
parejas de moléculas y veremos si se
pueden relacionar la una con la otra de
alguna forma digamos más o menos obvia o
quizás no tan obvia pero pero vamos a
ver si se relacionan los los primeros
dos que son estas dos verdes verdad
realmente parecen moléculas
completamente distintas así que a lo
mejor nuestro primer impulso nos diría
que son moléculas completamente
distintas y quizás no estaríamos del
todo mal pero si nos fijamos un poquito
más detalladamente en este de aquí que
tenemos a la izquierda podemos notar que
tenemos 1 2 3 4 carbonos mientras que en
el lado derecho tenemos también 4
carbonos verdad ahora bien si nosotros
contamos cuántos hidrógenos tenemos aquí
tenemos dos hidrógenos otros dos quedan
cuatro más dos son 6 1 son 7 y otros son
son 8 hidrógenos y del lado derecho
tenemos 2 468 y finalmente también
podemos observar que tenemos un oxígeno
en estas dos moléculas así que realmente
la fórmula molecular de estas dos de
estas dos moléculas es c 4 h 8 o verdad
entonces tienen la misma fórmula
molecular y es por eso que decimos que
son isómeros verdad son isómeros por
tener la misma fórmula molecular pero
además son un tipo especial de isómeros
verdad en esta situación no tenemos los
mismos enlaces verdad tenemos cosas
distintas
los enlaces realmente son lo que son
diferentes verdad la forma en cómo esta
estructura de esta molécula así que es
por esto que llamamos a estas 2 isómeros
constitucionales ok entonces estos son
isómeros constitucionales
y que en términos prácticos nos dice que
son las mismas cosas lo que estamos
uniendo pero son moléculas distintas ya
que
los enlaces entre los átomos son
esencialmente distintos vamos a ver este
de abajo este que es amarillo
y en principio podríamos pensar que este
carbono que tenemos aquí es un carbono
que irá al verdad es un carbono
asimétrico porque está unido a cuatro
grupos distintos tenemos el flor el
flúor perdón el hidrógeno el bromo y un
grupo metilo verdad y lo mismo pasa del
lado derecho así que tenemos este
carbono verdad este carbono central
digamos
y aquí tenemos que está unido a los
mismos átomos mismo oa los mismos grupos
verdad eso quiere decir que tienen los
mismos digamos los mismos elementos
estas dos moléculas tienen los mismos
elementos y tienen además los mismos
enlaces verdad todos los enlaces
realmente son iguales verdad por ejemplo
tenemos el enlace carbono con flúor
carbono con flúor carbono con hidrógeno
carbono con hidrógeno hasta acá bajo
carbono con bromo carbono con bromo y
carbono con el grupo metilo con carbono
con el grupo metilo
y a lo mejor a primera instancia nos
podríamos preguntar bueno será cierto
que son imágenes espejo o las imágenes
especulares y en realidad es que no
verdad
este este de la izquierda verdad
y una forma de verlo es por ejemplo si
nosotros rotamos toda esta molécula
digamos así de tal suerte que este grupo
metilo termine estando de este otro lado
vamos a ver si podemos dibujarlo vamos a
ver si podemos dibujarlo aquí tendremos
nuestro carbono verdad nuestro enlace
con el grupo metilo verdad
y bueno como cómo quedaría el enlace con
el bromo como se encuentra sobre la
misma hoja hicimos una rotación digamos
de 180 grados
entonces el bromo sigue sobre la misma
hoja verdad aquí estaría el bromo verdad
ahora este flúor que estaba afuera de la
página digamos apuntando hacia nosotros
quedaría hacia adentro verdad entonces
tendríamos el flúor más o menos
el flúor y tendríamos ahora el hidrógeno
verdad ahora tendríamos el hidrógeno que
está apuntando hacia nosotros ahora bien
si nosotros hacemos una rotación de este
estilo digamos rotamos alrededor de este
eje verdad de tal suerte que ahora el
hidrógeno pasa a la posición del bromo
verdad el bromo pasa a la posición del
flúor y el flúor a la posición del
hidrógeno entonces estaríamos obteniendo
justamente la imagen que tenemos a la
derecha así que realmente estamos viendo
dos formas o más bien dos estamos viendo
a la misma misma molécula verdad solo
que está rota da en el espacio vamos a
irnos con el siguiente vamos a ver aquí
tenemos otro ejemplo este este ejemplo
rosa
y podemos ver que son moléculas al menos
muy parecidas
aquí tenemos este carbono que está unido
un grupo metilo un hidrógeno y un flúor
verdad lo mismo pasa del lado derecho y
luego estamos uniendo con un ch 2 aquí
está el ch 2 también que a su vez se une
un carbono unido a un cloro hidrógeno y
grupo metilo verdad pasa lo mismo en
ambos lados y de hecho podríamos
observar que este carbono es un carbono
que irá al verdad está unido a cuatro
grupos esencialmente distintos el flúor
el hidrógeno del grupo metilo y todo
este grupo que claramente es muy
distinto a los otros tres verdad lo
mismo pasaría con este otro carbono
también es un carbono quiral
así que cada una de estas moléculas
tiene 2 carbonos quirales verdad y
parece que están hechos al menos de las
mismas cosas verdad y no solo no sólo
están hechos de las mismas cosas sino
que los enlaces están hechos de la misma
manera verdad así que
podemos observar que aquí tenemos un
carbono unido a un grupo metilo pero por
ejemplo difieren en digamos en el
arreglo tridimensional por ejemplo de
los enlaces del hidrógeno verdad que uno
apunta hacia atrás mientras que otro
apuntó hacia apunta hacia adelante lo
mismo ocurre con el flúor con el cloro y
con el hidrógeno en estos dos casos
verdad o más bien quiero decir en estos
tres casos para el flúor el cloro y el
hidrógeno
y como vimos un poquito antes en este
mismo vídeo vimos que los isómeros
constitucionales están hechos perdón los
isómeros estructurales están hechos de
las mismas cosas pero las conexiones son
todas distintas verdad y quizás debería
decir que es lo mismo decir un isómero
estructural o constitucional como lo
anotamos antes en el vídeo y son las
mismas cosas pero las conexiones son
todas distintas
ahora los estéreo y soneros están hechos
de las mismas cosas las mismas
conexiones son las son las mismas
conexiones pero la configuración
tridimensional es un poco distinto por
ejemplo en este carbono en el primer
carbono tenemos el flúor apuntando hacia
nosotros y el hidrógeno hacia atrás
mientras que en el carbono de la derecha
el flúor está apuntando hacia atrás y el
hidrógeno apunta hacia nosotros
y la forma en la que podemos ver muy
bien que estas dos son imágenes espejo
es como exponiendo digamos son imágenes
especulares es como poniendo un espejo
detrás de esta molécula yo sé que
siempre hemos manejado espejos que los
ponemos de esta forma verdad y vemos que
al reflejarlo se ven así pero bueno este
caso es un poquito distinto porque la
molécula es más complicada y si nos
fijamos en si pensamos que el espejo
está detrás de esta molécula entonces lo
que vamos a ver aquí digamos reflejado
es un carbono verdad y el átomo que está
más cercano al espejo es el hidrógeno
entonces en ese caso veremos que el
hidrógeno apunta hacia fuera verdad más
o menos hacia afuera mientras que el
flúor por estar más cerca de nosotros
estarán más lejos en la imagen espejo
verdad se verá
como algo así mientras que aquí estará
el ch 3 y aquí estará el ch 2 verdad lo
mismo va a pasar por ejemplo con este
otro carbono con este otro carbono como
el cloro está más alejado de nosotros
está más cerca del espejo entonces se
verá más o menos así mientras que pasa
lo contrario con el hidrógeno verdad
quedará más alejado de nosotros visto en
el espejo y terminamos nuestra molécula
y si nos fijamos en esta molécula blanca
que hemos dibujado en el espejo podemos
ver que es exactamente la misma que
tenemos a la derecha verdad entonces por
eso es que estos son estéreo isómeros
estéreo
so menos
muy bien y no solo son este luis homero
sino son una clase especial de stevie
someros que hemos ya mencionado
anteriormente y estos son enantiómero es
verdad son enantiómero
dio menos
son una clase especial de estéreo
isómeros y de hecho decimos que son
enantiómero en anti húmedos el uno del
hotel el uno del otro verdad y
simplemente porque son digamos las
mismas son estéreo isómeros están hechos
de los mismos elementos tienen los
mismos constituyentes también tienen las
mismas conexiones solo que esas
conexiones están un poco arregladas o
más bien están arregladas de forma
distinta en su configuración
tridimensional y más aún podemos decir
que esta molécula de la izquierda es la
imagen especular de la molécula de la
derecha y es por eso que les decimos en
anti o menos verdad así que vamos vamos
a vamos a ir con el siguiente ejemplo de
este ejemplo que ahora es azul verdad y
este se parece mucho al ejemplo que
teníamos anteriormente verdad tenemos
exactamente el mismo arreglo de carbono
es verdad grupo metilo carbono ch2
carbono ch2 carbono metilo verdad lo
mismo pasa con ambos digamos que los
arreglos
muy similares pero pareciera en
principio que a lo mejor podrían ser
imágenes especulares verdad el una de la
otra y eso sí a primera vista podemos
ver que son estéreo y so menos verdad
este carbono está unido a un hidrógeno
un bromo a éste sh3d 11 h 2 lo mismo
pasa acá este carbono de aquí está unido
a un hidrógeno cloro ch 2 dice h 2 lo
mismo pasa acá abajo y este último
carbono está unido 11 h 12 h 3 cloro e
hidrógeno verdad y lo mismo pasa abajo
entonces definitivamente son estéreo
isómeros la pregunta es si son imágenes
reflejadas o imágenes especulares la una
de la otra y bueno realmente para decir
que son estériles o menos tendríamos que
ver que en efecto
no sólo tienen los mismos elementos sino
que son su arreglo tridimensionales
distintos no porque a lo mejor podrían
ser la misma molécula entonces vamos a
ver que este carbono está unido este
hidrógeno que apunta hacia afuera
mientras que acá apunta hacia atrás lo
mismo pasa con el bromo éste apunta
hacia atrás y aquí apunta hacia adelante
aquí el hidrógeno apunta hacia adelante
y acá apunta hacia atrás el cloro apunta
hacia atrás y aquí apunta hacia adelante
y aquí el hidrógeno apunta hacia
adelante y aquí también apunta hacia
adelante y el cloro los cloro se apuntan
ambos hacia atrás entonces
definitivamente son estéreo isómeros
verdad vamos a ver ahora si son
enantiómero si podríamos utilizar la
misma técnica del ejemplo anterior vamos
a poner un espejo detrás de esta
molécula
un espejo detrás de esta molécula y
vamos a ver si esta de aquí es la imagen
reflejada de esta que tenemos arriba
entonces por ejemplo podríamos podríamos
pensar en este carbono tendríamos aquí
el carbono el bromo estaría apuntando
más cerca del espejo verdad entonces
quiere decir que se vería algo así lo
mismo pasaría con el hidrógeno verdad
aquí está más alejado y por lo tanto
perdón aquí está más alejado del espejo
lo cual haría que se vea mucho más
alejado en la imagen reflejada esto
quedaría igual verdad sigue sobre el
mismo plano
ahora qué ocurriría por ejemplo déjenme
hacer un poco más espacio
algo así verdad qué ocurriría con este
carbono bueno pues este hidrógeno está
apuntando hacia nosotros lo cual haría
ver en la imagen reflejada que apunta
hacia atrás verdad mientras que el cloro
apunta hacia atrás de nosotros lo cual
haría que apunte mucho más cerca de
nosotros en la imagen reflejada verdad y
aquí tendríamos nuestro ch2 y qué
pasaría con el último carbono pues el
hidrógeno apunta hacia nosotros se vería
que apunta hacia atrás en la imagen
reflejada y por el contrario con el
cloro se vería que apunta hacia nosotros
verdad
así que si ahora comparamos con la
molécula que tenemos abajo bueno podemos
ver que en efecto el hidrógeno apunta
hacia atrás el bromo hacia adelante el
hidrógeno aquí hay perdón aquí está
apunta hacia atrás lo cual coincide acá
el cloro apunta hacia adelante y aquí
también apunta hacia adelante pero en el
último caso el hidrógeno apunta hacia
atrás mientras que aquí hacia adelante y
el cloro aquí apunta hacia adelante y en
este caso apunta hacia atrás entonces no
podemos decir que son enantiómero si
podemos decir que son estéreo isómeros
son estéreo isómeros porque básicamente
tienen la misma estructura verdad eso lo
que a lo mejor tienen un arreglo
tridimensional distinto pero no podemos
decir que son imágenes especulares no
son el reflejo el uno del otro así que a
esto se les llaman de forma distinta y
éstos
los días estéreo menos los días te veo
menos siempre me cuesta mucho trabajo
pronunciar esto pero básicamente un día
estéreo mero es es justamente un estéreo
y somero que no es la imagen especular
no son imágenes especulares el uno del
otro verdad y por eso le vamos a llamar
de asterio mero y siempre que me cuesta
mucho trabajo decirlo por eso es que me
gusta primero escribirlo y los días tere
o menos son esencialmente éste louis o
menos que no son en anti o menos eso es
todo lo que significa es un estéreo y
somero que no es un enantiómero verdad y
un estéreo y somero sólo tiene dos
posibilidades o es un enantiómero o es
son de asterio mero vámonos con el
último ejemplo tenemos este está
estructura cíclica verdad que podemos
observar
y no sólo eso sino que además en el
grupo 1 y 2 tienen un bromo verdad bueno
ya sea este pc del 1 y éste el 2 o al
revés no importa verdad entonces
en principio parece que son imágenes
espejo verdad y de hecho si lo son si
nosotros ponemos un espejo aquí en medio
está la imagen de la izquierda es la
imagen reflejada de la de la derecha
verdad entonces estas dos son imágenes
especulares el uno del otro
perdón la una de la otra
y de hecho podemos ver que este carbono
es un carbono que irá a la verdad está
unido a un bromo a un hidrógeno y bueno
uno puede rápidamente ver que como en
este carbono de aquí no tenemos un bromo
pues son esencialmente grupos distintos
a los que está unido sobre este anillo
lo mismo pasa cuando tenemos cuando
consideramos este carbono verdad sin
embargo si observamos muy bien las dos
moléculas lo único que tenemos que hacer
para llegar de la molécula de la
izquierda a la molécula derecha es rotar
en esta dirección verdad si nosotros
rotamos obtenemos esencialmente la
molécula que tenemos de la derecha
entonces sólo solo son dos formas
distintas de observar la misma molécula
estos ni siquiera son estero isómeros
son la misma molécula y eso lo podemos
ver porque podemos superponer podemos
superponer sobre su imagen sobre su
imagen reflejada
su imagen especular digamos
una imagen especular muy bien
y de hecho bueno esta estos no son no
son compuestos que ir al es verdad y eso
lo podemos ver porque tenemos una línea
de simetría aquí es decir si nosotros
también tenemos esta línea de simetría
es lo que nos garantiza que podemos
girar esta molécula hasta llegar a la de
la derecha ahora bien estas dos
moléculas no serían las mismas si yo a
lo mejor en vez de bromo hubiera puesto
aquí flúor verdad lo mismo tendría que
haber hecho de este lado verdad para que
sean imágenes especulares si así fuera a
la hora de rotar aquí tendría que
aparecer el flúor verdad y sin embargo
está el bromo en ese caso sí que serían
imágenes especulares perdón si son
imágenes especulares pero además si
sería una molécula quiral y en ese caso
no tendríamos esta línea de simetría
verdad entonces serían imágenes
especulares pero no se pueden superponer
verdad eso si cambiamos el bromo por el
flúor verdad en este caso sí que se
vienen anti o meros
esto justamente lo que hemos observado
aquí si quitamos si regresamos al
ejemplo original verdad en donde tenemos
solo bromo es verdad
a esto se le conocen como compuestos més
o compuestos meso y no sería un
compuesto mes o si tuviéramos el flor
verdad en este caso sí serían
enantiómero es verdad
y en ese caso si no fuera un compuesto
mes o si no que fuera un enantiómero
tendríamos dos distintos en anti o menos
algunos recibiría el la dirección r
verdad como hemos visto en los vídeos
anteriores y el otro recibiría una
dirección ese y tendríamos que ir con
las convenciones de nomenclatura que
hemos aprendido